zombie doctors cranky gods and your
friendly neighborhood swamp monster were
just some of the surprises that MCU
throws Us in 2022 and did you catch the
latest mutant reveal
Moon Knight was by and large Oscar
Isaac's show the accomplished actor
who's as comfortable in Blockbusters
like Star Wars as he is in Intimate
drummers it's a fitting choice to play a
superhero with a disassociative identity
disorder one of his alter egos are
Stephen Grant a meat Museum gift shop
employee another is Mark Spector a
competent mercenary who is the Avatar of
the Egyptian god konshu hello man in the
mirror
I was wondering if you'd pop up again I
know you're scared a bit yeah
Steven meets Layla elfuli an Indiana
Jones type archaeologist who is also
specter's estranged wife she's upset
that her husband has abandoned her and
Stephen can't believe it ever screw
things up with such an incredible woman
Layla spends most of the series with an
ordinary awestruck scared and confused
Stephen it's fun to watch her as she and
this Alter Ego of her partner in love
and Archeology and cover tombs and
Escape henchmen still actress Mae
calamari never has much to do as Isaac
and there isn't much development of a
character that hints the last dark twist
however in the finale Layla becomes the
Avatar of to where it's the Egyptian
hippo goddess in an attempt to stop
Harrow and the god of judgment Ahmet her
transformation into the mcu's version of
the Marvel Comics character Scarlet
Scarab complete with metallic Wings
extended makes her one of the most
exciting moments in Moon Knight
Moon Knight proves that the MCU likes to
keep us guessing until the very end fans
of the Moonlight Comics always knew that
Steven and Mark shared their body with a
Third identity Jake luckily he was often
portrayed as a cab driver with a busted
nose readers anticipated Oscar Isaac
might get the chance to play this
grittier alter ego and the show was
peppered with subtle Clues throughout
for example whenever Moon Knight
resorted to extreme violence the
audience rarely saw it and Steven simply
came too disoriented most fans assumed
it was Mark causing the Bloodshed but
some suspect that it was actually Jake
in a Trippy sequence at the end of
episode 4 Mark and Steven are trapped in
a surreal psychiatric hospital and
passed by a logged sarcophagus which
leads to speculation that Jake is
trapped inside the season finale does
not actually confirm likely's existence
but in true MCU style a mid-credits
scene leaves no doubt a man wearing
black leather driving gloves Wheels
Harrow out to a limo and rudely dumps
him inside the driver then kicks the
wheelchair aside as Harrow confronts
koncho who has been waiting in the back
seat we then learn from the Moon God
himself that Mark and Stephen are both
off the hook for all of the previous
murderous Mayhem because luckily had
been there all along happily doing the
gods bidding
rumors were running wild throughout
fandom the major celebrities and some as
of yet unseen characters might have made
their MCU debuts in Doctor Strange in
the Multiverse of Madness a trailer for
the film featuring Patrick Stewart's
voice only added to the speculation that
Professor X and the Illuminati could
appear in the sequel sure enough part
way through the film there was Charles
Xavier seated next to Black Bolt Captain
Carter Carl mordo Captain Marvel and
Reed Richards while it did not come as
much of a shocked at us 838's Illuminati
made an appearance of Multiverse of
Madness what threw fans for a loop was
how director some Remy chose to deploy
them the X-Men and the Fantastic Four
have been eagerly anticipated additions
to the MCU but the filmmakers totally
pulled the rug out from under audiences
with won the maximoff incomplete and
terrifying villain mode killing off each
member of the Illuminati in creative and
disgusting ways
foreign
scriptwriter Michael Waldron's
devilishly hilarious bait and switch
gave fans what they thought they wanted
then took it all away in spectacular
fashion
with Sam Raimi The Man Behind The Evil
Dead in the director's chair fans
expected the MCU to head into some
groovy new directions but they couldn't
have guessed even strange and his evil
doppelganger would literally fight to
the death with musical notes in one of
Marvel's most inventive battles yet
doctor strange and the Multiverse of
Madness is full of Remy style flourishes
that are as playful as they are gruesome
from a giant eyeball getting impaled
with a Street Lamp to wonders chilling
jump scare the movie doesn't pull any
punches even Bruce Campbell as pizza
papa is doomed to punch himself
repeatedly
it's over
all the madness comes for Crescendo in a
dark and daring Final Act to defeat
wonder and save America Chavez strange
616 stream walks into Defender strangers
to cane corpse conveniently stashing a
rooftop shed in his Universe The Souls
of the dam derived to stop him since
possessing dead bodies as a major No-No
but he wins them over a demon enhanced
zombie strange complete with broken
fingers and chunks of his face missing
holds off Wonder long enough for America
to show her the error of her ways this
time it's gonna take more than killing
me to kill me
the mcu's second television series of
the year was responsible for some
notable firsts not the least of which is
that Ms Marvel is centered around the
Studio's first Muslim superhero Kamala
Khan who is a 16 year old Pakistani
American living in a Jersey City
apartment with a supportive yet strict
family when the series begins all she
wants is permission to attend avengercon
and cosplay as her Idol Captain Marvel
however her folks disapprove so she
sneaks out her best friend and one of
many potential love interests Bruno
makes her a pair of gloves for the
costume contest but she forgets them in
the bathroom instead she throws on a
mysterious heirloom bangle bracelet
which appears to turn her into a
superhero in her own right six episodes
later when it seems that the department
of damage control has been dealt with
Bruno breaks the most important news Ms
Marvel has to offer before leaving for
Caltech he tells Kamala that she
possesses a genetic mutation which means
her powers don't come exclusively from
the bracelet and Kamala is actually
a mutant for get Patrick Stewart's Cameo
on Earth 838 this is what fans of X-Men
have been waiting for since Disney
acquired Fox just in case audiences
thought it was a coincidence Shogun has
added a few bars of the animated X-men
theme music to the scene for good
measure
about a year before Thor love and
thunder premiered fans learned that
Russell Crowe would be joining the MCU
as Zeus while Zeus was both a fixture of
Greek mythology and a character in
Marvel Comics Crow is best known for
portraying serious often conflicted
characters like Maximus and Ridley
Scott's Epic film Gladiator given those
credentials many expected Crow zoos
would be a mighty if not somewhat dour
guard instead Crow gave fans a glimpse
of Zeus so they'd never seen him before
as Zeus turned loose sporting fobish
ringlets and ill-fitting breastplate and
making pronouncements in a ridiculous
Greek accent it was immediately clear
this one's mighty king of the Olympians
have been entirely transformed by
director taika waititi's trademark brand
of comic relief Crow Zeus prances around
with his toga mini skirts pings between
his fingers and threatens to ban anyone
who upstages him before the annual orgy
he's a riot and an effective foil to
Thor embodying an apathetic God who is
everything Gore the god butcher loves
you a Thor
god of thunder
but it's not under just the sound of
lightning
the headlines are unfollette and thunder
mostly had to do with Natalie Portman's
return as Jane Foster not only that she
was getting promoted to True co-star and
would appear alongside Chris Hemsworth's
Thor as mighty Thor Jane
when fans speculated about the plots
they mostly wondered whether she might
be the one wielding me on here going
forward others wondered whether
Christian Bale scored the god butcher
might live to threaten the mcu's growing
cast of gods in future installments what
no one saw coming was that Thor love and
thunder would end with a god of thunder
becoming a foster parent to Gore's
daughter a little girl named love Thor
functionally adopts a child but the
mystery remains how long will he stay in
dad mode and what part little love will
play in the next MCU phases
the first ever Marvel special
presentation werewolf By Night dropped
onto Disney plus around Halloween with
minimal Fanfare it was a test of sorts
for one-off stories I didn't warrant to
feature length film or a multi-episode
Arc that werewolf by night was so good
was a pleasant surprise the primarily
black and white Lo-Fi mini monster movie
is a throwback to horror classics from
the 1930s and 40s like Frankenstein and
the Wolfman but it has a strong voice
all its own and an aesthetic unlike
anything else in the MCU when human
Monster Hunter Jack Russell arrives at
Bloodstone Manor viewers know that he is
designed to undergo a transformation
this meant that the best trick werewolf
by night had up its sleeve was a double
reveal lurking in the Hedge maze in a
scare worthy of its vintage Inspirations
a giant arm burst through a Shrubbery
and grabs Jack by the chest a split
second later we discover it belongs to
man thing a popular character from 7-0
Marvel Comics further we learned that
jack isn't a hunting man thing their
best Birds is infiltrated as a cult
occasion a significant risk to himself
to bring his friend before they
assembled assassins can torture and kill
him man thinks the Zion and a sweet
relationship with werewolf by Knights
were definitely two unexpected
highlights of the mcu's 2022 lineup
the second special presentation of 2022
was the Guardians of the Galaxy holiday
special a parody of a Christmas special
that was filmed concurrently with
Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 3. this
40-minute musical mashup is even more
irreverent than Guardians usually is and
it's stuffed full of gleeful Easter eggs
the plot revolves around drugs and
mantis wanting to get Peter Quill the
best Christmas present ever his hero
Kevin Bacon the actor was referenced in
the first film when Star-Lord cited
Footloose before his climactic dance
battle with Ronan bacon doesn't just
make a cameo either he plays a
significant role
ah dude calm down I'm not gonna hurt you
that's a talking raccoon I'll kill you
however the Guardians of the Galaxy
holiday special ends with the
developments that matters much more to
the MCU in the long run man says has
been keeping a secret it turns out she's
ego's daughter which means she's Quill's
half-sister and she is afraid to tell
pizza because it might dredge up painful
memories about his mother's death after
the presents have been exchanged and
Kevin Bacon heads home mantis decides to
tell Peter and as one would expect in a
holiday special he is thrilled at the
news that he a mantis a family
after dozens of films MCU fans know to
stick around for Mid and end credit
Stingers which often have two purposes
they give filmmakers one last gag and
more importantly they tease new story
lines and characters it's a tradition
that goes back to the very beginning and
2022 was no exception but the audiences
meeting at least three new additions to
the mcu's roster first up audiences
finally got to meet the much tease Jake
lockley the most violent of moon
Knight's alter egos another surprise was
the appearance of Charlize Theron as a
Multiverse traveler who confronts Doctor
Strange in the street he follows her
into what appears to be the dark
dimension but not before an ominous
third eye manifests on his forehead
though she is only named in the credits
Theron is clear Doctor Strange's love
interest from the comics next in thought
love and thunder a myths Zeus with a
gaping hole in his chest calls upon
Hercules to avenge him of course with
Bob Iger reinstalled as Disney CEO and
the MCU reassessing its path forward it
remains to be seen what role any of
these newcomers will play in the future
[Music]